un edificio de apartamentos en llamas en
pleno corazón de la ciudad de mariupol
un enorme agujero en el techo testimonio
de otro bombardeo en el principal puerto
ucraniano en el mar de azov la ciudad
lleva sitiada varios días siendo blanco
de cañones lanzacohetes y combatientes
del ejército ruso el miércoles la
artillería golpeó áreas residenciales
incluidos un hospital de maternidad y
una escuela hiriendo a 42 personas según
el ayuntamiento las condiciones de vida
son cada vez más difíciles
otra vez nos quedamos sin electricidad
estamos otra vez sin agua y seguimos sin
poder calentarnos
en una señal de que rusia está
preparando una ofensiva aún mayor ayer
lanzó un ultimátum a los civiles
ordenándoles salir antes del jueves por
un corredor humanitario pero las
autoridades locales los acusan de
impedir esta fuga si mariupol está en la
mira es porque este puerto de 441 mil
habitantes tiene una importancia
estratégica para moscú tras la captura
de gerson miércoles si cae mariupol toda
la costa ucraniana que bordea el mar de
azov pasará a control ruso y la toma de
esta ciudad permitiría a moscú asegurar
la unión entre sus fuerzas procedentes
de crimea y las que llegan de los
territorios separatistas del noreste en
la ciudad varios miles de soldados
ucranianos se han atrincherado y
resisten por el momento los ataques
rusos